e
e e
time being 1010 I'm going to open the
public hearing on HP
660 and uh recognize representative om
to introduce the Bill thank you Mr
chairman I'm here to introduce House
Bill
660 with an amendment requiring histor
racing facilities to compensate their
host communities with 10% of the HHR
winnings so the current situation we
have is that we've had the uh expansion
of historic horse racing into fairly
large properties without having a opin
referendum which was normally part of
private part of previous Casino
bills and in fact when we've done
expanded gaming we've had um an opt-in
provision for Kino and for sports
betting so uh we don't have the opt-in
situation for the HHR build consequently
we don't have any mitigation for local
uh factors involved with large
casinos so as I pointed out in previous
testimony which I had passed out and
would introduce again into the record uh
we have some evidence from a study
called uh Casino crime and Community
costs that indicate the uh projected
cost for a city that's going to host the
large
casino and I
will introduce this into the record I
don't have to go through the bill again
be the copy because you've already heard
all this
commentary but the uh goal of the bill
is to provide this mitigation to the
cities and towns I'm asking for 10%
mitigation uh I have an amendment in the
Bill which is in front of you with the
changes highlighted in
yellow and the amendment makes the
Charities
whole from the bill itself the original
bill is drafted would take a little ding
to the Charities little dink to the
state this leaves the Charities hole
leaves the state hole and only takes the
10 % to be mitigated to the local
communities solely out of the operator's
take and that's the
bill questions yes do we have questions
represent shamberg thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question
representative uh the the 10% mitigation
fee why 10% versus maybe not five or six
was this to make it easy easy for
someone to figure out percent called
negotiation I'll ask for 10 I'll sell it
from
five save some
time other
questions yes representative Spar thank
you chair you said that the purpose was
to raise more revenue for the
municipalities um is there an issue
right now or with these municipalities
and not having enough Revenue coming
from the tax assessment and other other
areas yeah that's a Perpetual issue but
this uh doesn't deal with that
longstanding problem of Municipal
spending and how to allocate funds what
it does do is try to address a specific
incremental cost and that goes back to
the uh document that I've passed out
previously to try to Define what is that
incremental cost and can we get some
mitigation just for that
cost it won't do anything else to the
city budget but'll cover the uh expenses
that the city's like likely to incur
should they have this kind of a
Enterprise in their District thank
you representative ducet thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question do you do you have uh reason
did the city come to you and say they've
incurred fees charges uh upticks because
we've heard testimony about this and and
the testimony we've heard is negligible
so and and this would be in effect a
retroactive tax yeah it's um it's not a
tend to be retroactive it's tend to be
proactive going to the Future uh the
cities of town have not come to
me uh they haven't experienced any
mitigation issues at the present time
and in fact the uh mitigation issues are
likely to be down the road particularly
in the threee in in the time period
after about 3 years is when you start to
see these costs come into effect per the
study so no there's no cost right now
there's no need for a instant mitigation
right now but I think down the road it
would be appropriate to uh set the
structure in place for such
mitigation
followup thank you and thank you for
taking my followup um like I said we
we've we've heard uh testimony about
potential impacts those haven't come to
fruition and maybe a retroactive word
isn't the one I'm using we sat passed
legislation this this was a component of
that testimony we heard at the time we
passed the legislation and this is a
component that the legislature chose not
to include so
um I'm I'm in a town that has a gaming
facility my police chief and and Fire
Chief and subsequent other Public
Service uh Chiefs haven't directed me
that they're having issues with this so
um I just wanted to clear up my
statement if you you're seeing something
different in Nashua uh Manchester and
others would we're not getting an outcry
from from the municipalities that host
these uh charitable Gaming facilities so
uh and like I said we've we've heard the
testimony and decided against this type
of
tax yeah I appreciate your comments and
I agree with you they haven't seen any
uh cost issues or concerns right now I
bring this up primarily from past Casino
bills that have been uh run through Ways
and Means over the past 14 years and
typically on a comprehensive Casino bill
there's a lot of additional language
Beyond just a simple authorization of a
device which we had in the HHR
authorizations we didn't have language
for many other factors the other factor
that I'm talking about which had been in
Prior Casino bills which did not pass
but had been in the proposals in
comprehensive Casino bills were for
local
mitigation um there's a bill that
represent Ames had which uh I took some
language from there's been other bills
that set aside uh funds for various
concerns
and uh because we didn't have a
comprehensive Casino bill with the
HHR uh enabling
legislation I feel that we should think
about some of these additional factors
that were determined to be important for
full-fledged
casinos follow I would respectfully
disagree it was a quite comprehensive
bill I was on the bill and we heard you
know extensive testimony in relation to
that so I think it's something we
visited um I think this might again be
an issue that the upcoming commission
gaming commission would look at
but all right that's a that's a would
you believe
question represent Aly yeah I just
wanted a clarification does this apply
only to new
casinos this this bill would apply to uh
anything that's in place at the time of
the
bill or anything that comes after yeah
or comes after thank
you any other anyone else seeing none
thank you representative thank you next
I
have Alicia Preston
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Alicia Preston I
represent the New Hampshire charitable
gaming operators Association and we are
here in opposition to this bill as we've
testified before on other ones we know
of no other industry that is
specifically uh kind of targeted to say
you have to pay to the municipality
differently than any other business if
you look at the requirement of Municipal
services from any industry uh The chle
Gaming facilities are asking no more of
any town or city
than a bar a sport venue a concert venue
or any other entertainment that is out
there so this is very specific to one
industry and uh for that reason we do
oppose this
legislation thank you represent elme yes
um that may be true in New Hampshire it
is not true anywhere else uh but on you
were talking about sports venues and
things like that we don't have them in a
number of the places where they have put
these
casinos uh
and and they provided uh they
stonewalled our zoning committee on when
or rather I think it was the planning
committee when it came to traffic
studies on the major East West Route um
represent elme can you pull the
microphone closer to you
sorry on the major East West Route
across New Hampshire to
Vermont on we have not
seen a lot of extra traffic yet except
when it was opening I'm not sure how
many people are actually going to it but
um as our representative M said
uh we have historical data now on what
happens when casinos move into different
kinds of cities
and um and in every other part of the
country they are col they are
collecting
this but we decide in Live Free or Die
state that we're not going to do that
what is your what is your question my
question
is uh when you talk about we don't do
this you mean New Hampshire don't you I
do thank you
yes represent elberger thank you thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for taking
my question you mentioned other kinds of
Enterprises that are not being asked to
uh pay more and you specifically
mentioned if I remember correctly uh
bars uh restaurants and sporting and
concert venues and entertainment venue
yes
do you
have any sense of what the
relative um
Revenue uh the benefit to the owners of
those establishments are compared to
gaming I I have no
idea not specifically no what I know is
that as these facilities grow they pay
more property taxes than they did the
day before just like any business that
grows I also know anecdotally I live at
Hampton Beach we have two of these
facilities and I can assure you from my
own experience and witness that
Municipal services are far more required
at some of the uh other entertainment
industries that we have there and they
are not specifically required to pay
more to the municipality and again the
bigger the facility whether it's a bar
restaurant entertainment venue or gaming
facility the more property taxes they
pay which more than compensates for any
Municipal Services they would receive
and again as with all these businesses
they don't put children in the school
system which is the largest cost factor
for any municipality in the
state thank you for your answer I I
don't appreciate the comment about
children excuse me represent
elberger followup uh representative you
said question so if a business is
profitable in one year they make more
money than they did last year do they
pay more business tax
yes sir okay secondarily to that um is
there any other business that you know
of in the state of New Hampshire that
has very strict security requirements to
negate what may be an impact on the
community and I'm talking about security
presence physical Personnel cameras on
every
location um subsequent
details that that's paid
for I mean to the restrictions that are
on this particular industry is there any
other industry in the state that have to
meet that those requirements to my
knowledge no and those requirements are
both in statute and in Rules From The
Lottery
Commission thank you any uh anybody
else okay seeing none thank you very
much thank
you and I just want to remind members uh
when we have somebody
uh up we we're there to ask them
questions um we're not we're not here to
make statements um about what we think
about what they're
saying okay is there anyone else who
would like to testify on HB
660 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on HP
660 okay time being 1025 we've got about
five minutes before the next hearing
thank
you
okay all right when did this did they
send this today okay
you
e
e e
okay the time being 10:31 I'm going to
open the public hearing on HB
658 FN and uh welcome
up uh Bob Scully
is he introducing the bill wait a minute
um I'm sorry wait a minute U who's
introducing the
bill um do we have anyone from uh
environment and agriculture or somebody
who's introducing this
bill
okay um
was it
18 representative Malloy will introduce
the bill and um I'll just ask you to
fill out a pin card later
thank you Mr chair Dennis Malloy
Greenland
Ry uh here to introduce uh House Bill
658 FN raising the cap on certain
reimbursements from the oil discharge
and Disposal cleanup fund and I won't
take any
[Laughter]
questions could you explain this to us I
just kidding well I could read the rest
of the analysis into the record if you'd
like me to yeah okay thank you okay
thank you you can explain
okay um represent Aly would you like to
go up and
testify oh
Myers cheaters
good morning uh representative Susan Aly
uh can you pull your microphone closer
for some reason it's not uh try to pull
this strange chair a little bit closer
um and I just want to explain a little
bit about the history of of this bill
this disposal oil discharge and Disposal
cleanup fund has been in place at
least since 200000 I think probably long
long before that uh and it was
created on we were told in 2008 when we
dealt with this um because it kept on
being uh its life span kept on being
extended and the people behind me would
know better
on why it needs to be extended again but
the the fund was
created I believe at the request of the
oil companies because in this is what we
were told in 2008 um because the uh
insurance companies refuse to cover oil
spills uh because they can be incredibly
expensive
sometimes and they have no way of
telling when they might happen this
particular part of of that is um about
leaky
tanks uh and particularly people who
have tanks that are leaking inside their
basements or inside their property that
um do not have enough money to remediate
it and therefore if it keeps on leaking
it's going out to the street it's going
out to all the neighbors and it is a
hazard
um they may totally refute this when you
listen to them but this is what we were
told back in
2008 uh and it is an insurance policy by
the state paid for by the oil companies
at their
request and um we keep on thinking that
they will run out of leaky tanks but
apparently they are not and I think you
should just listen to Dees okay thank
you
represent and if you'd fill out a pink
card as well I'd appreciate it okay I've
got uh wait a minute
I guess first we'll hear from uh Bob
Scully thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I appear in support of
House Bill
658 FN I am here representing the energy
marketers Association of New Hampshire
which is an association of home heating
oil companies throughout our state of
New Hampshire so
uh this fund is actually collected as an
import fee um on the fuel that comes
into the
state is how this revenue is generated
if you look at lines 18 through 21 on
the bill you'll see different areas of
products of
fuel depending on the amount of product
that comes in is where they generate the
funds from and these numbers in this
proposed legislation has been massaged a
little bit some of it goes up some of it
goes
down in relationship sh to underground
storage tanks that fail um this fund was
set up to try to provide um Revenue to
help
mitigate um environmental hazards to
help replace tanks for those individuals
that could not afford to do so um and
some people's Insurance do cover it but
we work with Department of Environmental
Services to try to ensure that um we
limit and we provide financial
assistance to those who need it to
replace tanks um and industry does
support this build but just to be clear
um all these little add-ons or that you
see this bill eventually do make their
way down to the consumer I mean it's
it's not eaten by the oil company so um
I'm I'm happy to try to answer any
questions I know Dees is behind me and
they can probably go into a very
distinct detail for you right represent
elberger thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question as I'm
looking at the rates you mentioned that
they're going up and down some are going
up and some are
down as far as I'm able to
interpret and that that's not this my
forte here it looks like
the part that is going up is or one of
the parts that's going up is for the on
premise
heating that's the second number second
set of numbers that that's
listed uh let's
see on line 20 online 19 line 19 yes
that that number is going up and that is
um uh it's home he yes correct how was
the why why these particular number why
are these particular numbers changing in
the direction they are I'm just trying
to understand the so there is it's
called an odd fund committee a group
that meets they're the ones that put
this together I am not on that committee
representative Edgar um the prime
sponsor of the bill at CZ and night
committee along with Senator Howard
Pearl um in my discussion with both of
them was that this is what that
committee hashed out probably also um I
think they sat down with um uh someone
had helped do an audit of their work to
make recommendations and my brief
discussions with them on these numbers
and the trending of where these numbers
are going um to try to make sure that
this fund stays solvent that's the
extent of my knowledge okay thank you
yeah yes uh represent opal thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question and perhaps if you can answer
it the representative from Dees can but
I I'm I'm a little confused and I'm not
a lawyer so um it's probably not
surprising but on line 15
it says any person who Imports or causes
to be imported oil into the state except
those using oil pipelines railroads and
highways to transport oil products
between states other than New Hampshire
or for international
transport
so am I understanding that the only
people who have to get licenses are
people who are
not not not importing oil from other
states or internationally or they I'm
going to defer to them representative
that's okay thanks Mr chair if I could
deferm my question till the next witness
that is fine yes I was just uh texting
the um Prime sponsor to see if he's
available to come down as well um okay
thank you thank you Mr
chairman okay the the other two the
other two pin cards I have are from
nhdes so I'd invite you both up uh
Robert bishop and
Jennifer
Marts I'm don't know if I'm saying that
right morning Mr chair uh could you put
this speaker on thank you good morning
Mr chair and committee members my name
is Robert Bishop I'm the administrator
of the oil remediation and compliance
Bureau at the Department of
Environmental Services joining me is
Jennifer Marts she is our fund manager
ment section supervisor at the
Department of Environmental
Services the oil fund dispersement board
from which this uh Bill originated is
administratively attached by Statute to
the Department of Environmental Services
we carry out the administrative
processes of what the oil fund
dispersement board requests that we
do this bill impacts two different funds
it impacts the oil discharge and
Disposal cleaning fund as well as the
oil Pollution Control fund and it it
makes four changes to the existing
statutes those changes are one to change
the date due date of an annual report
the other to raise the cap on
reimbursements for lowincome homeowners
for tank replacement when they have a
home heating oil tank that is suspect
and may
leak it
also extends the collection of these
fees for 10 years the the previous bill
has an intentional Sunset of 10 years as
does this proposed Bill and then it
adjusts the fees on the various types of
petroleum and all Petroleum in general
that's imported into the state u in the
statutory purpose of both funds it's to
cope with the problem of oil spills
petroleum us used so much throughout
society and the general court saw that
there was a problem with petroleum
products and the impact that they could
have on human health and the environment
groundwater resources Drinking Water
Resources the I call it the odd fund so
that's the the one administered by the
oil fund dispersement board oil
discharge disposal fund it reimburses
responsible parties for cost to
remediate oil spills at compliant tank
storage facilities so that is the actual
cost of corrective action and what this
is is excess insurance so if there's any
insurance available that will cover that
cost of remediation if that insurance
doesn't exist or is expended then the
odd fund comes in and pays for those
corrective action costs at these oil
spill
sites also the odd fund helps to uh
prevent oil spill releases part of our
prevention program including that four
mentioned safe tank program which is the
replacement of home heating oil tanks
for low-income home owners and it
satisfies both Federal and State
financial responsibility requirements
for owners of underground storage tank
facilities as was mentioned
previously that it was one point and I'm
not sure about the difficulty currently
to obtain insurance for underground
storage tank system
but there was this requirement put on
federally to have money Financial
Assurance to be able to pay for release
from your us and this fund also
satisfies that requirement the oil
Pollution Control fund the other fund
that's affected by this bill is for the
agencies emergency response spill
response and prevention efforts so that
includes that's financial support for a
24-hour day 7 day per week 365 day per
year spill response program primarily
responding to petroleum releases but
about 90% of the releases we respond to
are petroleum and there are about 300
responses that are performed per year to
those spills primarily of petroleum
releases for this committee I I believe
the important part to know is about
those fee changes and and those
expenses and the oil fund dispersement
board hired Taylor and Moulder an
Actuarial firm to
review the expend the anticipated
expenditures of the odd
fund and that was using information
going back 10 years information compiled
by the department on current sites
information about future use and
exposure depending on types of tanks and
tank systems that are in
place and
then compared that to oil import volumes
as long along with us Energy Information
Administration data on fuel usage in New
Hampshire uh both for gas and Diesel so
motor fuel as well as home heating oil
fuel and with that they tried to
balance the which category of fee pays
for which type of spill SO gas and
Diesel paying for releases from tanks
that have gas and diesel fuel home
heating oil playing for releases or fuel
oil paying for releases from on premise
use facilities which are typically home
heating oil tanks motor oil
paying for releases from motor oil tanks
and then there there there's one other
fee and it's it it's called all other
oil in the in the bill or in in the
statute but it's actually on all oil and
that portion there is for the oil
Pollution Control fund that is the spill
response side of of
operations that explains some of the
strange numbers going out to far decimal
points and that this was based on an
Actuarial review and was attempting to
balance those costs across the different
types of oil that's imported into the
state
and with that they were looking at the
after this 10year time period
when this bill this statute will sunset
again that we were left with enough to
pay that fiscal Year's administrative
costs as well as a quarter of the
anticipated reimbursements for a fiscal
year so those are the corrective action
reimbursements and currently we we
maintain a balance of $1.5 million in
order to have the first three days of a
major Coastal oil oil spill covered in
that oil Pollution Control fund because
we could see the state having to pay
those first expenses
until the federal oil spill liability
trust fund comes in and starts paying
for those major spills we have quite a
bit of oil stored along the pascar river
and that is is the reason for having
that balance in order to be able to
address those first few days of an oil
spill I know there were there were some
questions asked before of the the other
uh
commenters and may need reminder on
those questions okay thank you um I just
want to ask the actual Actuarial review
is that is are these recommended new
changes from that review
process the the Actuarial review came
out with the with them exactly balanced
the oil fund dispersement board looked
at that and they found that the fuel oil
fee was going to have to go up over 200%
to pay for those releases from on
premise use facilities home heating oil
that is our largest category of new
releases that occur there are about a
hundred a year in that category for all
of our other tank systems that are
eligible the number of spills that occur
from those systems is is typically less
than 10 total per year
and those systems have regulations that
are enforced by the Department of
Environmental Services SO gas stations
they have regulations they have to
adhere to regulations applying to home
heating oil systems are strictly within
the National Fire Protection Association
standards and those uh have minimal
enforcement or requirements uh with
those and so the this the board decided
that it was going to be too much to
balance that particularly on the fuel
oil side so they proposed that the fuel
oil fee goes up 100% instead of that 200
I think in 18% so more than uh doubling
and rebalance the other fees based on
that so that did that continued to
result in the gas and Diesel fee
dropping it was going to drop a little
bit more if those particular spills were
balanced across the fees pipes so that
that is the difference from what the
actual review found okay thank you uh
yes represent
op thank you Mr chairman and thank you
um I I I had the unfortunate experience
in 2010 of spending a significant
portion of my summer helping the
secretary of the Navy um develop a
recovery plan for the Gul Coast in the
wake of the deep waterer Horizon um
spill and I became way too familiar with
the oils build liability trust fund um
which as I am trying to remember 15
years ago as I understood the fund it
was created to deal with spills for
which there was no identifiable
responsible party is that your
understanding well so there can be
identifiable responsible parties but
they are potential responsible parties
until the legal process works through
and so there right so there'd be
reimbursement excuse me that trust fund
will come in and it will pay reimburse
State costs Mr chair I follow up follow
up so what um what I was trying to get
to in my other question was I as I read
uh lines 13
through 15 or 16 I guess I'm not clear
who is covered here it it it sounds
like well I'm just not clear who's who's
covered it it sounds like anybody who
brings it in by rail um pipe or Highway
which other than Port that's the only
one that's left out so I mean are we
trying to do just cover the ports or so
U what this covers is oil that use its
destination of use is is in New
Hampshire oil that just passes through
the state as part of Commerce doesn't
get an oil import fee so if it goes
into goes into a gas station in the
state goes into a home heating oil tank
it's going to get used in New Hampshire
then that applies I believe this is an
interstate commerce issue and why that
is carved out yeah one more followup Mr
chair okay and I I'll just remind
members too that the policy committee
we're a second committee the policy
committee has has given their okay on I
forget what the vote was 18 to nothing
or whatever we're focused on do these
numbers make sense go ahead and
represent opal what I what I was going
to ask Mr chair is if it's possible to
obtain the numbers that that back up the
data here in other words you know over
the last 10 years your actuarials used
information regarding how many spills
how many claims names how much was you
know appropriated um or spent um and how
you came to that and I just would make
that request yes we can we can provide
the Actuarial report it it is U I
believe a 60 plus page report I have the
the 26 page executive summary of it here
with me but happy to provide that and
that is using a a number of different
data sources and Actuarial techniques to
come up with the projection
I I'd be fine with the executive summary
thank you Mr chairman representative ORS
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question so real quick as just you
said there's about a 100 private spills
a year that are identified isn't are we
identifying these through a dying system
or whatever and isn't there is there a
preventative plan to clean this mess up
so we're not dealing with it after the
fact
so there there are a few
different cave caveat or places within
the answer to that um the home heating
oil releases of which typically a 100 a
year and probably about 60 to 70 of
those are paid for through this fund
those get called in typically by the
homeowner or the fire department and
they call in Dees and our spill response
team goes to that home home and assist
the homeowner with the things that they
need to do to have that spill properly
remediated and to ensure that it doesn't
have a long-term impact on their
groundwater or their indoor air quality
within the house uh that fuel is dyed
but that dye is is for other tax
purposes that are federal so it's dyed
red the home heating oil it's very it's
essentially diesel fuel it's the same
type of fuel then we have the universe
of tanks that are regulated such as the
gas station underground storage tanks
and there are significant Federal and
both state regulations the state
regulations are authorized through the
federal process to take their place and
we get very few spills so less than 10 a
year total from all of those and
typically those spills no longer are
coming from the tank they usually coming
from the piping or a sump or something
associated with the tank or an overfill
when the delivery truck comes and and
drops the uh the fuel into that
underground storage tank so they the the
category of home heating oil there are
just not regulations that apply there to
prevent those
spills okay follow up so are most of the
home heating oil in iences are they the
result of sloppiness or degenerating
tanks or pipes or yes the majority of
the spills are from the tanks U rusting
rusting from the inside out and then
having a pinhole leak or something
that's larger it's in a basement or it's
outside and doesn't get noticed right
away until all 275 gallons have been
released out of the tank representative
Brier uh yeah just uh on line 13 I think
it's beginning uh section three and then
on line 28 section four on the oil
Pollution Control fund you have a
effective date of July 1st of um
2025 and and I understand why that is
but my question is um when uh you talk
to safety about the collection process I
believe there's like
234 uh uh oil discharge and pollution
accounts are about 135 Distributors
approximately and my question is usually
they have a little lead time where they
got to notify the Distributors about a
change in the tax rate they also have to
call the vendor to make sure that they
have time to update the system and the
third thing is uh sometimes the
distributors in the oil pollution
controls need a little lead time to uh
update their ACC tax software systems so
my only concern is on those two
sections did safety give you any
indication of the lead time they needed
to I'm I'm just saying this July 1 thing
might be a little tight by the time this
pass and gets if this passes and gets
signed by the governor how much lead
time does the department of safety have
to implement these
changes we we haven't had that
discussion with the Department of Safety
as of yet we do have a member of the
Department of Safety on the oil fund
dispersement board Jennifer Hall and I
think that's a a good thing for us to
bring up with her Jennifer actually
reached out to me and asked the question
when um everything was going to be
finalized so we're we're in discussion
right we're in discussion right now
Jennifer Hall and I are in discussion to
um for her so she's talking to me about
the lead time we haven't talked about an
exact date but I have had discussion
with her Mr chairman followup followup
so I I the only I understand this whole
I'm very familiar with this subject and
my only concern concern is that and uh
I'm thinking that you might need an
amendment to compensate for that lead
time to give the Departments enough time
to implement this properly so they can
notify their their uh pay taxpayers or
licenses and I'm just thinking there
should be some sort of amendment to
account for that uh administrative
time represent
YY yeah if this were to pass with the
timeline we have now all that means is
it not correct that all that means is
that then the board would be a to
implement immediately any changes that
they pass through the re uh regular
administrative
process I think I need that clarified
I'm I'm trying to address the uh issue
of uh time and lead and everything else
once the law is in
effect then the board can put it into
effect when they set their own rules and
change rates is that correct I I believe
the way it's written it will go into
effect on July 1
2025 follow up yeah followup andway once
it's in
effect then the boards would set the
dates and times and everything else for
the implementation of what was in effect
it's not an instantaneous we're going to
do it at this date because you still
have your administrative process
correct I I don't know the answer to
that hold in
office I think what what he's trying to
what he's trying to get to is um if the
date is still set at July 1 does the um
in the billing process uh behind the
scenes could this be taken care of in
other words it's like okay you can
notify people that the price went up but
you may still be billing them at the old
price but at the next bill it be caught
up so instead of us doing an amendment
can this be handled internally I believe
that would be reasonable and that would
be available to the
board we be the board's decision on how
they okay representative
yri yeah to get back on topic of what
we're dealing with this particular Bill
raises and lower some effects some
different charges in different areas
this is a realignment of the actual cost
to do uh the work that the uh odd people
do right yes so it's essentially
housekeeping and in construction that is
it's a making an adjustment up and down
to cover the needs of the odd board to
do the work that is being done yes that
is
correct is this a followup
is this a general increase to the
consumer or decrease or where where are
we in that scale yes this results in an
8% overall
increase of total import fee
Revenue all yes when you say import fee
Revenue we're now talking about any oil
product that is brought into the state
either by truck or by ship or train I
suppose some train
cars I doubt that
um that is sold at the at the
pump so the feet per gallon of a
gasoline is not necessarily reflected
because this would apply a cost gasoline
petroleum um oil household hold oil oil
that's sold in cans uh at
the oiles or wherever oil you get put in
if you you're too damn lazy to change it
yourself or don't want to get cold
laying on your
back is that correct that is correct so
that 8% is on the wholesale cost not the
retail cost is that
correct I don't think I'm in the best
position to answer that question as I'm
not a retailer and I I don't sell these
products and I would
I don't know how
they how they manage these
costs thank you represent
elmy yeah I was just wondering if we
could delay executing this bill and ask
for clarification from the odd fund
itself whether it would need an
amendment put on this to uh delay the re
requirement for the changes in the
funding until there was time to finish
administering doing it or whether they
can handle it
internally we we can do that we have a
board meeting coming up at the end of
this month if you onund dis first report
uh that's uh that's too late they won't
fit we have to get the bill out before
then
okay we'll figure that out yeah all
right any other questions talk to the
local sponsors all right I'm going to
close the uh public hearing on HB
658 all right
um e
okay we're going uh Republicans are
going into caucus stems as well we will
come back here at
1120 you're going no no we're staying
here
yeah uh we will reconvene we will come
back at 11:20 sharp um because we need
to get going on this thank
you
e
e e
ready well what's uh the first one is
uh okay the time being 11:23 we will get
started with our executive
session I'm going to open the exec
session on HB
155 and represent and um recognize
representative Brier for a
motion I'd like to make a motion to
retain do I have a
second all right represent shamber
seconds
it uh would you like to speak to your
retain motion
um I just think we should retain it to
uh see how revenues do over the next
year and uh take a closer look at uh
this legislation before we make a
decision on it thank you any
discussion seeing none they'll ask the
clerk to call the
role thank you Mr
chairman we are voting on house
bill5 relative to the rate of the
business Enterprise textt the motion is
retain representative
alry
I representative duet yes clerk votes
yes representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
Stevens Smith yes representative
Tierney pleas
out representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative Aly yes
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative lit yes
representative elberger yes
representative
Davis yes representative
Opel yes representative Spar yes
chairman San
I have
19 to makes sense the vote being 19 to
zero for retain the committee will the
committee will retain HB 155 and I will
close the exact session on HP
155 next I will open the executive
session on HB
417 and recognize representative Brier
motion I'd like to make a motion to
retain do I have a
second second by representative Aly
would you like to speak to your motion
kind of the same thing as the previous
one let's see how revenues come in this
year and uh take a look at it next year
see how things uh pan out sounds good
any
other comments represent El me uh there
was something that came up in the
hearing about a complicated interaction
with allowing Municipal Val valuation of
polls and conduits that would have to be
solved if this was
repealed but
um maybe if we decided we wanted to do
that we could solve that
too oh maybe maybe uh uh the this
complicated interaction with allowing
Municipal Val valuation of polls and
conduits that they've been trying to get
forever um would um could be solved if
we were going to figure out we didn't
really need the revenue next year thank
you anybody else uh representative Brier
did you have something else or you your
your microphone is
on okay I'll ask the clerk to call the
role thank you Mr chairman we are voting
on house Bill 417 the motion is
retain the bill is relative to the
repealing of the Communication Service
tax representative
alry yes representative ducet yes clerk
votes yes representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
Smith Steven yes representative
tney out representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative Aly yes
representative hackin Phillips yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative lit yes
representative elberger yes
representative Davis yes representative
Appel long o Opel yes thank you
representative Opel votes yes
representative Spar yes chairman denigan
yes yes
190 the vote being 19 to Zer the
committee will retain HB 417 and I'll
close the exec session on
it next up I'll open the exec session on
HB
585 and recognize representative Brier
for a
motion I'll make a motion to retain this
bill do I have a second second Mr
chairman representative shamberg seconds
the motion would you like to speak to
your motion uh yes uh based on testimony
and um it seems like there's some things
that need to be worked out on this bill
before it get uh before it's uh
recommended two pass and uh I think that
we should take a second look at it and
see what we can do to make the bill
better thank you anybody
else and I'll I'll just mention that
this uh this is a bill that I sponsored
and there are a couple of other bills uh
floating around uh representative
Pearson has a bill that is similar
that'll be um in the house before this
bill and while it doesn't have
everything this bill uh has in it um by
retaining it we can see how things go
there and um work on this in the future
anybody else seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role thank you Mr Mr
chairman we are voting on House Bill
585 relative to the property tax
exemption for religious organizations
the motion is
retain representative alri yes
representative ducet yes clerk votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes representative Stevens Smith yes
representative
Tierney out representative Brier yes
representative Mary for
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Aly yes representative
hackin Phillips yes representative mooy
yes representative shamberg yes
representative lit yes representative
elberger yes representative Davis yes
representative
Opel thank you yes representative Spar
yes chairman janigian
yes K Kirk clown
19 to Z okay the vote being 19 to Zer on
retain this uh Bill HB 585 will be
retained and I'll close the exec session
on
it next I will open the exec session on
HB
658 and recognize representative Brier
for a
motion I'll make a motion to uh a to
pass on House Bill 658 do I have a
second
represent duet seconds
it would you like to speak to your
motion yes uh what this does is it makes
some adjustments to the uh environmental
uh fees that are collected for the oil
uh oil uh disposal and Pollution Control
fund uh it's basically housekeeping and
some adjustments of fees that cover the
cost to inure uh on premise heating
systems uh oil tanks in uh cleaning up
oil
spills thank you representative duet
yeah just for clarity Mr chairman uh the
issue we heard in the testimony is
apparently something that can be
addressed in any other body so uh
whatever concerns might be with the
implementation of
this okay there is a concern yeah
represent El me
and you have guarantees of that
the issue was possibly the my
understanding was the the date um and it
possibly can be handled within the um
the department but um if not then the
other body could potentially change that
uh
date there would have to be two
dates one that
extended the
the the uh life of the
program and then the second one uh to to
um uh set in motion all of the
funding
so I would hope that at this point the
people that are listening could go and
work on that issue in order to bring it
to the Senate because the Senate
probably won't think of
it okay representative
Brier um it's my understanding that
Senator Pearl sits on the oil fund
dispersement board and that um there's
the
ability as uh represent El pointed out
um there is a uh there is two issues
there's the sunset it needs to that
needs to be straightened out immediately
but also uh the other piece is when the
uh the rates go to effect they just need
like you know my estimation be like 60
days to just clean up some of the
administrative stuff to notify everybody
and change the system and I believe that
uh that can be uh adjusted in the Senate
well and based on what we heard about
when this next meeting would be that
would fit in the time frame for the
Senate but not for us um and could you
also follow up with Senator Pearl I I
can
okay thank
you all right any other anybody else
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role thank you Mr chairman we are
voting the motion is ought to pass on
House Bill
658 raising the cap of certain
reimbursements from the oil discharge
and Disposal cleanup fund representative
alry yes representative ducet yes clerk
votes yes representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes Representative
Steven
Smith no representative tney is tney is
absent representative Brier yes
representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
Aly yes representative hackin Phillips
yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative love
yes representative elberger yes
representative Davis yes representative
Opel yes representative Spar yes
chairman janigian yes clerk counts 18
to1 okay the vote
being 18
to1 it um well it cannot go on consent
because it's uh um got as an
FN so it passes and um I'll close the
exact session on HP
658 a Minority
Report will there be a Minority
Report I'm guessing
no will there be a Minority Report okay
okay next I will open the exec session
on HB
660 and uh
recognize representative
M thank you Mr chairman I
I Mo I move vote to retain this bill I
believe the bill needs some additional
work on the terms okay hold on uh do I
have a second second Mr chairman second
by representative shamberg
and would you like to speak to your
motion yes uh Mr chairman as we've just
heard I think the bill needs some work
and I vote to retain the bill for that
additional
work anybody
else seeing none the clerk will call the
role we're voting on House Bill
660 requiring historic horse racing
facilities to compensate their host
communities with a percentage of the
revenue generated from their HHR
machines the motion is
retained representative olry yes
representative ducet yes clerk votes
yes representative sodi yes
representative ores yes Representative
Steven Smith yes representative T is
absent representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative
Aly yes representative hakin philli yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative lit yes
representative elberger yes
representative Davis yes representative
Opel I representative Spar yes chairman
janigian yes I count 19
Z the vote being 19 to zero um HB 660 is
retained in committee and I'll close the
exec session on it
I'll will now open the exec session on
HB
688 and recognize representative ORS for
a motion thank you Mr chairman I motion
that uh this legislation is inexpedient
to legislate do I have a
second any the motion's itl
do I I'll second second by
representative
Brier and would you like to speak to
your motion yes thank you Mr uh chairman
yeah I'm I'm just uh I see this as a uh
an unnecessary tax increase directed
specifically at a particular
industry thank you any other uh
representative uh Aly yes on I feel that
on
that the sponsor who I co-sponsored with
is um searching um for a way to get
municipalities the compensation that
they deserve to have for containing a
casino in their grounds and um I so I am
on I don't want to see too many of these
bills go forward
so so uh I am happy with the
itl okay uh representative
Opel
oh okay no problem seeing no
other questions or comments uh I'll ask
the clerk to call the role thank you Mr
chairman the motion is itl on House Bill
688 authorizing municipalities to tax
tradable Gaming facilities based on
their Enterprise Value
you representative alri yes
representative duet Yes Prime sponsor
votes yes representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
Smith yes representative T me is absent
representative Brier yes representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
representative Aly yes representative
hackin Phillips yes representative
Malloy yes Representative shamberg no
representative Bol correction
representative lit yes Representative
elberger no representative Davis yes
representative Opel I representative
Spar yes chairman janigian yes I count
17-2 17-
two okay the vote being
17-2 is this uh is there objection to
consent by those who voted no no
objection to
consent okay it's itl
though we learned that last
time
okay question by representative YY is
anyone going to write a report
or well if it's going on consent I would
say no it
a report no no I'm sorry it's still
going to have a report I meant I thought
you meant a Minority Report uh
representative ORS will write the report
um for the majority okay it'll go on
consent and I'll close the executive
session on HB
688 all right last but not least I'll
open the exec session on hb7
37 and recognize representative ducet
thank you Mr chairman I move itl on HB
737 do I have a
second second representative Murphy
feature to
it uh would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chairman um this
exact same language is covered in HB 247
which got unanimous
OTP vote yesterday so there's no need
for this
piece okay anybody else yes represent El
me I didn't quite understand that
somebody had a session yesterday he
today h today Municipal and County
Municipal and county has the same bill
is that what you're saying same language
same exact language okay and they did
what they unan unan iously got passed
out of committee ought to
pass I I have it right here
representative I can ship down your way
if you
like anyone else
it's did someone amend
it did it get amended doing that's the
amendment the amendment is what passed
yes and we don't have time to read it
but what are the differences between the
two
yeah we know the differences my
understanding is that the original
language did not cover the applicants
that are in the queue for the HHR so
they corrected that with the amendment
so it's doesn't add anybody but includes
everybody that's
uh
qualifies thank you I thought that that
was covered by yourid existing language
but Mr chairman yes repres I I just took
a a thank you I just took a quick look
online and unless the amendment changes
the language it says it only authorizes
a referendum regarding historic horse
racing I
think is that all that's covered under
games of
chance let's uh why don't we take five
minutes to look at that Amendment
yeah
don't what
cop yeah it there's it says games of
chance versus horse racing and they're
not the same
correct the
amendment they are't the same not sure
the but on as far as I'm concerned
that's an
[Music]
improvement because a lot of people find
poker a a innocuous
game um what
would would it repres elberger would
this cover um thoughts or the the the
new U machines that the governor is
proposing in her
budget and if not I don't see these as
equivalent uh representative duet no
repr UL representative duet you
mentioned that the uh action by
Municipal and County
uh negated the need for this bill but
there are there other reasons that this
bill should not be in uh passed by this
committee yes
yes Mr yes chairman I would like to ask
that this bill be uh moved to the next
executive
session so that we have time to absorb
this
um I see that bill
fore
yeah it's the amendment is a
full new page of material
representative Aly is it appropriate for
our
um us to call a caucus to have some time
to review this before if the chairman is
inclined to call the vote
who can speak
up I I'm going to recess this uh Bill to
the next executive session
uh Mr chairman procedurally yeah there
was a a motion in a second do we have to
remove
that
no that uh yes represent just set uh
that at the next executive session when
it comes up this will come up and the
motion on the floor is itl
covering the bases that's
yeah okay well that
um that closes uh today's that concludes
today's session um or committee meeting
I should say um I do have a couple of
other items to
mention um next
week my plan will be to schedule
this bill as well as um I mean at this
point now we've
got nine bills left in the committee
that we haven't acted upon uh but we
just did six just now so we're down to
three uh this will be one of the things
we take up next Monday the
10th um and I know I had said previously
that I'll try not to schedule Mondays
however uh Tuesday the 11th is uh town
uh meeting day and voting and uh the the
uh speaker's preference is for us to try
not to schedule committees on March 11th
which is Tuesday so uh I'm planning on
I'll schedule something for Monday the
10th uh and the things that we will take
up will be uh this bill um and
um anything anything else uh remaining
needed to be done uh Bill wise as well
as we will look at uh the appropriate
portions of
hb2 which are pertinent to Ways and
Means um and so that will be um you what
you'll see is that'll be recorded as a
work session um on a full committee work
session on the relevant parts of hb2 to
Ways and Means and um we will and then
we don't actually we we we may vote but
it's more to just get our thoughts so we
can I can transfer that to the finance
committee um our thoughts on the ways
and means portion and um I will um send
out so it'll just it'll be General like
that in the calendar but I'll send out
um the pages that are relevant in the
hb2 to the committee so you'll know what
to look
at repres elme thank you I had heard a
rumor or two two rumors actually that uh
Finance was sending us the um SL
machine bill bill at the governor
included
to take a look
at um
we we we will look at well are you
talking about hb2 I mean hb2 that's part
of what we're going to look at yeah yeah
thank you
right
okay um and I guess lastly I heard uh
some uh desire to have a field trip to
uh the Nash um and um I know the local
NASA people were thinking about doing
that but maybe it's good for the full
committee um how do people I guess by a
show of hands who would be interested
in
food no we don't we don't have it
scheduled it's just um you know it would
be a field the Nash is a
casino in NASA n thus thus the word Nash
and it's two and a hours away from my
house is it well you may not be someone
who wants to go
faster all right just to show our hands
who thinks they're interested I mean
you're not committing but okay so
there's general interest all right thank
you Porters available at the door we'll
see what we can uh yeah talk to
Jordan have anything else uh represent
Opel um is is the intent to meet at 10:
on Monday the 10th the intent would be
to meet at 10: on Monday okay yeah
andely we're doing hb2 also go all
day uh it's I would plan on a day we
don't know what I haven't thought
thought of the order yet of how it will
be but um
yeah um
yeah my understanding on the the way
that it's being set up to review hb2 is
is that it's reviewing only the revenues
and estimates not yeah not the policy
that's going to be whatever it
is anybody else with questions yes
represent elberger Mr chairman are you
going to get in touch with the Nash or
do you want some of the Nash or reps to
do it um that'd be great if we'll we'll
talk about that offline okay thank
you okay yes represent Brier
when do you need that uh majority report
on
uh thank you uh actually are there any
minority reports let's see no minority
reports looks like yeah looks like no
minority reports is that correct it
looks like based on the votes here okay
so the there are one two there's only
two majority reports representative ORS
and representative
Brier
um when can you get get it done ASAP is
always
nice okay so today being Tuesday um 1
noon tomorrow if you can get it to me
right before noon tomorrow that would be
preferable especially if it's early in
the morning tomorrow that would be much
appreciate it you do it now great okay
thank you that's all I
have
e
e for